thank you
so there are a few things that bring us
humans together in the way that an
election does we stand in elections we
vote in elections we observe elections
our democracies rely on elections we all
understand why we have elections and we
all leave the house on the same day to
go and vote we cherish the opportunity
to have our say
to help decide the future of the country
the fundamental idea is that politicians
are given mandate to speak for us
to make decisions on our behalf that
affect us all
without that mandate they would be
corrupt well unfortunately power
corrupts and so people will do lots of
things to get power and to stay in power
including doing bad things to elections
you see even if the idea of the election
is perfect
running a Country-Wide election is a big
project and big projects are messy
Whenever there is an election it seems
like something always goes wrong someone
tries to cheat or something goes
accidentally awry
a Ballot Box goes missing here Chads are
left hanging over here
to make sure as few things as possible
go wrong we have all these procedures
around the election so for example you
come to the polling station and a poll
station worker asks for your ID
before giving you a ballot form and
asking you to go into a voting booth to
fill out your vote when you come back
out you get to drop your vote Into The
Ballot Box where it mixes with all the
other votes so that no one knows how you
voted
well what I want us to think about for a
moment is what happens after that after
you drop your vote Into The Ballot Box
and most people would go home and feel
sure that their vote has been counted
because they trust that the election
system works
they trust that election workers and
election observers do their jobs and do
their jobs correctly
the ballot boxes go to Counting places
they're unsealed and the votes are
poured out and laboriously counted
most of us have to trust that that
happens correctly for our own vote and
we all have to trust that that happens
correctly for all the votes in the
election
so we have to trust a lot of people
we have to trust a lot of procedures
and sometimes we even have to trust
computers
so imagine hundreds of millions of
Voters costing hundreds of millions of
votes all to be counted correctly
and all the things that can possibly go
wrong
causing all these bad headlines
and you cannot help but feel exhausted
at the idea of trying to make elections
better
well in the face of all these bad
headlines researchers have taken a step
back and thought about how we can do
elections differently
they've zoomed out and looked at the big
picture
and the big picture is this elections
should be verifiable
voters should be able to check that
their votes are counted correctly
without breaking election secrecy which
is so very important
and that's the tough part how do we make
an election system completely verifiable
while keeping the votes absolutely
Secret
well the way we've come up with uses
computers but doesn't depend on them and
the secret is the ballot form and if you
look closely at these ballot forms
you'll notice that the candidate list is
in a different order on each one and
that means if you mark your choices on
one of them and then remove the
candidate list I won't be able to tell
from the better remaining what your vote
is for
and on each ballot form there is this
encrypted value in the form of this 2D
barcode on the right and there's some
complicated cryptography going on in
there
but what's not complicated is voting
with one of these forums so we can let
computers do all the complicated
cryptography for us and then we'll use
the paper for verification
so this is how you vote you get one of
these ballot forms at random and then
you go into the voting booth and you
mark your choices
and you tear along a perforation
and you shred the candidate list and the
bit that remains the one with your marks
this is your encrypted vote and so you
let a poll station worker scan your
encrypted vote and because it's
encrypted it can be submitted stored and
counted centrally
and displayed on a website for anyone to
see including you so
you take this encrypted vote home as
your receipt
and after the close of the election you
can check that your vote was counted by
comparing your receipt to the vote on
the website
and remember the vote is encrypted from
the moment you leave the voting booth so
if an election official wants to find
out how you voted they will not be able
to
if the government wants to find out how
you voted they won't be able to
no hacker can break in and find out how
you voted no hacker can break in and
change your vote because then it won't
match your receipt
votes can't go missing because then you
won't find yours when you look for it
but the election magic doesn't stop
there instead we want to make the whole
process so transparent that news media
and international observers and anyone
who wants to can download all the
election data and do the count
themselves
they can check that all the votes were
counted correctly they can check that
the announced result of the election is
the correct one
and these are elections by the people
for the people so the next step for our
democracies are transparent and
verifiable elections thank you